well I have not spent very much time
talking about Kanye West on this show
and that's partly because I figure
you're getting quite enough Kanye
content from every other podcast in the
world it's also because
a celebrity going around and saying
outlandish things is not the kind of
story that I find terribly interesting I
think there are much more important
things happening in the world and I try
to focus on those but yesterday's events
do I think call for some uh commentary
now that the man has fully completed the
process of his own self-destruction
there are some things that uh I think we
can learn crucial takeaways and I would
like to spend
a little bit of time talking about them
so as you've no doubt already heard
Kanye appeared on Alex Jones's show
yesterday afternoon the interview is the
Capstone on a week that began with the
rapper storming out of Tim Poole's
podcast after Tim offered gentle
pushback to Kanye's ideas
he did not storm out on Alex Jones
however though perhaps considering what
he said it would have been better for
him if he had again and again throughout
the interview West wearing a ski mask
completely covering his face for the
entire conversation
insisted on a point that he felt like it
was it was very important to make uh he
wanted to make it clear
that he thinks Hitler and the Nazis get
a bad rap and here he is introducing
that idea
that's right you're not Hitler you're
not a Nazi you don't deserve to be
called that and demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also the Jew I love everyone and Jewish
people are not going to tell me you can
love
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the contracts
and you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table especially
Hitler
especially Hitler
and somehow that was not the craziest
moment of the show later Kanye launched
into some sort of puppet act making fun
of Benjamin not Netanyahu and using a
bottle of Yoo-hoo and a net as puppets
and it took me a while to figure that
one out because I'm not you know I
usually I'm good with the with the puns
but net and Yahoo okay
um it's hard to make heads or tails out
of this but here it is
I was tired of picking up the Yahoo and
The netting so finale's just netting I
know some people call him Bibi another
some of you call them yeah yeah but
we're gonna call him netting
what you want then hey yay right after
this I'm gonna sell you crazy I'm gonna
take your family away from you we're not
done with you yet you cannot cause free
thought we have to control the history
books we have to control the banks and
we have to go and kill people also we're
in the vegetarian
so
and a little longer hopefully you're
gonna take the mask off because this is
this actually Yay here
right okay then and he also returned to
his Hitler Fanboy routine like I said
several times but um perhaps most
notably with uh with this
I like Hitler I don't like Hitler
you're trying to be shocking with that
I'm not trying to be shocking I like
Hitler I do not I the the Holocaust is
not what happened let's look at the
facts of that and Hitler has a lot of
redeeming qualities
so he said those exact words I like
Hitler multiple times at other points in
the show he also said that we need to
stop dissing the Nazis doesn't want to
diss them he said he doesn't like
describing Nazis as evil
and then Connie went home and hopped on
Twitter where he tweeted an image of a
star of David combined with a swastika
and he also tweeted multiple times in
support of uh Balenciaga claiming that
God loves the company and then saying
this quote I stand by Balenciaga and
denounce all witch hunts and I cancel
cancel culture Jesus is King ending
trafficking doesn't start or end with a
fashion campaign for Christ's sake
well no Kanye we we should absolutely
cancel companies that put out BDSM ads
featuring children they should be
canceled condemned boycotted I'm against
witch hunts too unless there's an actual
witch to hunt
but I suppose Kanye had already defended
Hitler so why not child pornographers
while he's at it eventually Elon Musk
suspended Kanye from Twitter what
appears to be as far as I could tell a
temporary 12-hour suspension ostensibly
because of the swastika image which Elon
said
is uh in an example of inciting violence
which is absurd obviously you either
believe in free speech or you don't Elon
is running the platform as a free speech
platform or he isn't you know it's one
of the other he said in the past that
people are free to post what they want
as long as they aren't directly calling
for violence against another individual
or group well
Kanye did not directly call for violence
what he posted and what he said to Alex
Jones
can certainly be described as
objectionable insane outrageous immoral
along with many other similar adjectives
but free speech means you're free to say
objectionable insane outrageous immoral
things
of course now there's there's an
argument you could make and I've seen
some people make this argument that
maybe Elon suspended Kanye for his own
good kind of like a a mercy killing
approach on social media just to get him
to cool down stop talking put down the
shovel that he was using to bury himself
and since Elon owns the platform he has
every right to make that call if he
wants to but if that's what Twitter is
now if Twitter is a kingdom and Elon is
the king and he gets to make the rules
as he goes along arbitrary as they may
be then then he should say that you know
again he has every right to run it that
way it is his platform he bought at fair
and square but he should say so for the
sake of honesty and transparency
what he's actually said is that there
will be free speech
and if that's what he's claiming he
should follow through on that even in
these hard case situations now as for
the rest of the story first of all
it should go without saying
I would certainly hope that it does
but just to be clear about this
um Hitler was a degenerate Mass
murdering lunatic so if you're gonna put
your own credibility on the line and
your reputation and your name and your
career and everything to defend someone
or to point out their redeeming
qualities quote unquote it shouldn't be
for the sake of one of History's
Greatest monsters and not incidentally
Hitler was also a man who by the way
would have thrown Kanye himself into the
gas chamber without hesitation Kanye is
rallying to the fence of a man and of a
group that would have considered him
sub-human because of his race
so this is pure self-loathing
self-immolating Madness
and on that point second
it's hard not to laugh about some of
this because it's so awkward and weird
and that's just the natural response
when you see something awkward and weird
but in in truth you know it's it's
actually not funny this man is having a
mental breakdown he's losing his mind he
is sick he is not well
he is in very bad shape
nothing could be more clear
and yet he has no one in his life
apparently who cares about him or loves
him because there's no one talking any
sense to him he surrounded himself with
vultures and parasites who have leeched
onto him and are feeding off of his
notoriety and encouraging him to plunge
even deeper into Insanity for their own
benefit
it is it is a pitiful spectacle to
behold
Kanye West was was truly once an
artistic genius and an important
cultural Voice once
but now he's eating himself alive on
camera
to the Delights of the gawking crowd
Kanye has built a bonfire and thrown
himself into it
if there was ever anyone in his life who
was willing to pull him away from the
Flames he's obviously cut them out at
this point leaving only the enablers and
the coattail Riders and now he is
hopelessly and helplessly spiraling into
the abyss and that's what we're watching
this is not an excuse for Kanye it's
simply an observation it gets very clear
the guy's just not well
and the fact is that Fame can drive
anyone into madness I mean once you
reach a certain level of Fame you're
living something that can barely be
described as a human existence you
become especially these days a product a
brand an entity
you're no longer viewed as a person but
but uh but you are viewed you're not
viewed as a person but you are viewed by
everyone all the time
you are you are on display all the time
you have none of the anonymity that
normal people take for granted no
privacy no ability to ever be just sort
of a face in the crowd and when you're
at Kanye's level
you're so famous that the people around
you can become famous second hand right
and so you find yourself surrounded by
self-interested Fame [ __ ] who
continually push you into the spotlight
so that they can have a piece of it for
themselves
and if you're already prone to
eccentricity as all artists are this
kind of uh this kind of Life can quite
easily destroy you which is why through
history we have seen
now the the self-destruction takes many
forms this is a rather unique form
but um certainly you know more common
things like artists you know succumbing
to drug abuse alcoholism suicide you
know those sorts of things again this is
not an excuse for Kanye it's just an
it's an attempt at an explanation as to
what we're seeing here
third Point perhaps most importantly
I would hope
that Kanye West's psychotic break which
is what this is
would be enough to finally dissuade
conservatives from falling madly in love
with any celebrity who says one thing
they agree with
you know Kanye West was
talking about this thing or that thing
kind of babbling and over the years and
he's made one or two comments that
conservatives liked and suddenly he was
a conservative hero
so on the right we've we've been
desperate for celebrity approval and
celebrity endorsement for so long and
it's like it's pathetic
and it's given rise to this unfortunate
habit of launching in latching onto any
famous person who ever so mildly or
tentatively affirms our position on any
topic
I would hope that this would be enough
to break that celebrity fawning spell
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with agreeing with a celebrity or even
congratulating them when they take a
stand on an issue
like you know a month ago or a month and
a half ago which feels like a million
years now but um
when he uh came out and and and spoke up
for The Unborn
there's like wrong at the time as I did
saying that's that's the correct view
I'm glad he said that
so there's there's that that's one thing
but what we shouldn't be doing is making
them into a standard Bearer a hero a
champion of the cause
yeah we shouldn't be doing that
automatically just because they're
famous
especially by the way you know one one
thing is like
somebody is famous and then they come
along out of nowhere and they say one
can serve one quote conservative thing
and
and then they become they you know they
they get put on this pedestal and it's
like they along with all the other
reasons why that's a problem to respond
that way it's also they haven't earned
it you know they haven't been in the
cause fighting for this they haven't
done anything for it
they just happen to say one thing
and in many cases these are people who
up to that point had been contributing
to the cultural rot
and they say one thing and it's just
it's an unearned position
which means that you also can't trust
the person
like they're going to disappoint you
and if I was optimistic I would say that
maybe the right will be smarter about
this kind of thing from now on but I'm
not optimistic
in fact some on the right seem to have
decided that they've boarded the Kanye
ship and now have to go down with it
which is which is really which is also
sad that's that's the you know that's
the word of the day here sad
because you don't need to
if you defended him in the past and you
were on the Kanye thing and you know and
it's okay to say now this guy's got
problems and then just move on with your
life you can do that
I've seen some defending him even still
looking for excuses coming up with all
these outlandish copes and
rationalizations claiming for example
that Kanye's pro-hitler stuff was just
him advocating for radical Christian
love love thy enemy they say but that's
not what Kanye said he made it clear
explicitly he likes Hitler you even say
love he said I like him like
okay the Bible does not call us to like
everyone
much less Mass murdering lunatics
you said you think it says he has a lot
of redeeming qualities a lot
he said we shouldn't diss the Nazis now
that's not loving thy enemy that's just
insane is what that is
it's also we should note
a really big favor to the left
okay who benefits from all this
well I mean they benefit from it in fact
if I was going to come up with some
conspiracy theory to explain Kanye's
pro-hitler pivot I would say that he's a
leftist on a Kamikaze mission to
embarrass and discredit as many
conservatives as possible now I don't
think that okay that's not the theory
that I hold I think he's simply mentally
ill as I've already covered but that's
the only conspiracy theory that even
would begin to make sense if you're
looking for one
because the left is the only beneficiary
here that's why they're so gleeful about
Kanye's plunge into madness they're not
upset about it they don't think it's sad
they can't get enough of it they love it
they they want him to be trending with
all this crazy stuff they love every
minute of it why wouldn't they why
wouldn't they love it I mean some of
their ideological opponents hitched
their wagon to Kanye and then Kanye
proceeded to drive right off a cliff
with those people attached which is a
which is a very fortunate turn of events
for the left
but not for anyone else
and especially not for Kanye himself who
is a troubled man who needs help
not attention
which is why now that I've said my piece
I will go back to what I was doing
before
and not give it to him
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the
aforementioned members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]